and finally new rule someone else
explained how one side sees this man is
the most prolific liar in history and
the other side says I like him because
he's authentic president Pinocchio
averages seven and a half lies a day and
yet his followers all say the same thing
he tells it like it is
he speaks what's left of his mind we
have never seen anything like this a man
totally insecure yet supremely confident
not a politician
but also the most politician ever bald
but with a full head of hair
[Applause]
trust me Trump is not concerned that I'm
a Rasta has some recording that will
blow his cover because he has no cover
he's like the water supply in Flint
Michigan no filter and the damnedest
thing about that is it's actually kind
of refreshing because in an age
dominated by the professionally offended
we secretly envy the man who was able to
speak his mind
Trump saw nation exhausted from
political correctness and said you want
warm and fuzzy stick your dick in enough
boot
[Laughter]
whereas the rest of us really live two
lives there's the real us the person in
the kitchen or a bar who speaks like a
human with trusted friends and then
there's what I call our avatar our
avatar looks and sounds like us but it's
not really us
it's the persona we adopt in any sort of
public sphere which now includes your
followers on Twitter and Instagram and
thousands of friends on Facebook you
know bad things go viral so everyone
fears any misstep that could cause
America's Pearl clutters to point and
scream at you like the end of invasion
of the body snatchers think of all the
people who've lost job offers because
there's a picture of them that got
posted holding a bong or having a dick
drawn on their face when they were
passed out
which i think should get you more job
offers because being passed out tells
employers what I do something I do it
110 percent Americans today crave any
kind of authenticity because our avatars
are just so full of [ __ ] a few weeks ago
the actress Amber Heard forgot to turn
her phone on avatar mode and tweeted
what was actually good advice for actual
people just heard there's an ice
checkpoint in Hollywood everyone better
give their housekeepers nannies and
landscapers a ride home tonight Oh No
some offensive because we all know
there's so many Jewish gardeners out
here I wonder if there was a Hispanic
man that night sitting in the back of a
paddy wagon thinking at least no one
assumed because I'm a gardener I'm
Latino that would be the real tragedy
ironic that we elected Trump because we
were so sick of politicians who were
inauthentic who were all avatar isn't
that why people hated Hillary but then
we became the politicians the everyone's
social media persona now is like a
candidate running for office holding
babies doing photo ops making sure every
statement is carefully sanded down so as
not to upset anybody Facebook should be
called to Facebook
it's funny in movies avatars or more
interesting versions of ourselves flying
around doing whatever they want but your
avatar and Facebook isn't better or
stronger or faster than you are it's
just prissy err it's great superpower is
it remembers birthdays folks if you want
to know who someone really is ignore
their avatar and check out their web
browser history there's a book out
called everybody lies that's about what
we search for on Google and according to
the author quote 30% of people
exclusively watch stuff that you would
find disgusting look at a list of
popular porn categories cuckolds
cheerleader stepmom double penetration
cream pie tentacle sex sounds like
sounds like we're playing password for
perverts things your husband wants but
you don't
on Facebook woman's top terms for
describing husbands are the best my best
friend and amazing but when women type
in my husband is on Google the top three
results are mean annoying and gay
they have to wonder if the more gland we
make our public avatars the more weird
we want to be at home anyone who works
that hard to appear moral in public is
usually a freak in private it's a theory
I don't have much evidence to support
except for every Evangelic imposter ever